palais lequel 17 l'acte lequel 17 a
longtemps été blot qu'elle n'essaie rien
et dans une plombe l'ont pas aidé c'est
frédéric 9 ans l induction sur canal ben
oui on se rappelle de votre chronique
dans cet épisode parents vous nous
expliquer comment savoir si son bébé est
malade regarder pour savoir si votre
bébé et malades du foie ou pas il suffit
de regarder son caca si le caca et de
couleurs vives
j'en ai d'ailleurs ouvert sans cesse et
que votre bébé est en pleine santé
mais s'ils seront kaka de couleurs
claires voire pas de couleurs du tour
c'est que soit votre bébé est un extra
terrestre soit qu'il est gravement
malades du foie mais feu pour les
enfants malades du foie et pour que les
gens regardent et chacun des bébés ouais
ce qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
mouraient à cause de ça et on a vraiment
pu communiquer là dessus très très
content d'avoir fait cette campagne
bah merci merci nous le lien même c'est
important merci lequel 17 et le meilleur
pour imiter des accents ces emplois est
étrangement mehdi là on est en plein
tournage alors de dire il nous tue en
rire toi jéjé malades dans le monde
dans le film tu me taxant brésilien oui
c'est bien ce passage là et bien
[Rires]
secrétaire brésilien
oui j'ai une secrétaire brésilienne et
que je veux absolument cher jean alias
adhérents soumet à touba où tout est ce
que tu peux faire moi là parce que tu
faisais le journal en arabe
c'était il ya longtemps est-ce que je
peux remettre un petit extrait mais bien
sûr à plaisir si l'on regarde je t'en
prie
broyé ou ne me sens chez moi mais dsk
dsk ou the bubble proches jantes alu
turbo avs abus de bien social médical
effectué c'est hyper bien imiter rocky
balboa way vucci 3 seulement vas-y le de
leucate pas du tout alors tu as deviné
la vérité c'est que j'ai peur de perdre
ce que j'ai au début je pourrais prendre
des gnons sur le ring je m'en foutais à
noailles à toi petit et je veux pas
perdre ça mais qu'est ce qu'on m'a dit
remplaçable quoi la voiture ou même le
pognon ou même de la maison mais on a
tout sauf la vérité rocky mais c'est
quoi la vérité
j'ai peur mais quelle 17 a très peur des
serpents mais là qui a très très peur
des serpents c'est quoi votre phobie
vous a parlé mais pas par ma barbe non
non non non la bave non ça va hamama les
autres ça va mais je sais que la mienne
vous dérange non non non non ce média le
souligner mais sinon je vais pas laisser
enfin je crois que c'est fait nous
menons mois que ces domaines
c'est fred tu veux savoir de fred
d'ailleurs rien comment elle doit le
savoir pourquoi garder son mariage
on était venu à fort boyard
si on était en phase de blanche c'est ça
et tu avais très très très peur devant
seulement alors que j'étais actualiser
la ouais mais là il a fait fort boyard
aussi ouais hein oh [ __ ] regarder des
extraits vous appris sur le buzz vous
avez
doucement du surjeu vous pouvez non je
suis je suis désolé je vous pouvez vous
pouvez pour porsche ou pas ça va
tranquille tient lequel 17 a lancé un
appel à steven spielberg il a proposé à
steven spielberg de travailler avec lui
lequel 17 à propos de steven spielberg
de travailler avec lui mekhissi qui a
proposé à un steven spielberg de
travailler avec lui c'est qu'il est
votre ambition clavier n'est pas du tout
le souvenir de ça mais peut-être ça
m'est arrivé mais non c'est pas vous
c'est moi ou c'est nous bah oui un
nouveau site a lancé un appel à steven
spielberg pour travailler avec lui et tu
vas voir
heureusement que c'est pas toi qui
reçoivent cette regarde le mister
spielberg a oui j'admets que movie is
you mais ce remake of what we did to gab
se calmer à quelle lose dinosaures et
d'oiseaux par faure et suit - tout un
monde de beauté à longwy synovate is the
bottom of the bottles là que big ben ou
que la cote de dictionnaires mise au
fond duquel calme et robin plein
visionner ces gens
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue mais ce serait être j'ai un
sale accents j'avouerai mais tu permets
traîner ali un sale accent il parle pas
alors oui c'est voir ça dans ta vie tu
as regardé l'émission ultérieurement
merci de ses habitants oui oui questions
non non je te bute et s'est énervé mais
bon il s'excuse énervé est-ce que vous
collez est ce que vous êtes tous
contents de jouer avec christian clavier
franchement c est ce que c'est un
aboutissement moi je sais que quand je
le reçois dans l'émission enfin je sais
moi je suis je suis c'est je le dis
aujourd'hui et je le dis voilà une fois
pour toute et je ne changerai pas d'avis
c'est mon invité préférées wen jeudi et
c'est vrai la numéro 1 et tous les
autres peuvent maps et peuvent vous dire
ici tout ça on va ils n'ont qu'à plus
venir à la mélodie à tous ceux qui nous
regardent oui il est numéro 1
voilà je vous le dis monsieur clavier si
on me sens très heureux
sinon je m'en fous je n'aurais pas été
engagée non mais franchement à boire
pascal aussi c'est un énorme c'est un
énorme comédien c'est une énorme
carrière est ce que vous êtes
franchement pour eux pour frédéric sais
c'est un truc de fou tu dois être un
méchant mais tout seul notice grandi
avec l'époque du splendid
bon j'exagère maintenant passer à autre
chose et quand j'étais en changer donc
sa balle s'est logée à regarder que vous
en avez rêvé par son nombre à sel
revient quand elle veut c'est devenir
noir chantal oui oui j'aime à dire
demander comment ils ont réagi lorsque
christian clavier a refusé de les voir
avant le tournage du film est la
première scène comment ça s'est passé
dans le camp est là
je voulais pas les voir au départ
maintenant ils sont installés
c'est un problème déjà dans le film ça
me fait passer les deux noms pour le 2
sincèrement je voudrais avaient été
dissipées du tournage c'était eux
s'étaient inscrits sur clavier si ça le
devient soir on était très calme ont été
très gentils et beaucoup plus à y avait
une pression ait eu des pressions je les
habille la pression à le faire foirer
exact est ce que le film va marcher la
deuxième fois et ou alors qu avec
chantal on s'en foutait complètement
extrêmement dissipée